Hey, this is going to bring great pleasure
to many in our audience.
It's time to say bye bye to me.
David Packman is leaving the David Pakman
show just for four shows next week.
Next week we're going to be having guests
hosts Monday through Thursday.
And then we are sort of wrapping the Memorial
Day holiday, uh, to include next Friday so
that staff gets a, an additional day off in
addition to, uh, the federal holiday.
So we're going to be having guests hosts for
the first, first part of next week, Ben Dickson.
We'll be splitting guest hosting duties with
Farron cousins from ring of fire.
Uh, I'm going to be combining my much overdue
vacation, which I skipped.
People may not know this.
Um, I, I martyred myself so that everybody
else could get a vacation early in 2019 and
I skipped mine and I am now going to be taking
a few days off combining it with a trip to
a wedding and, uh, sort of a, a work trip.
Um, and then we'll have the memorial day holiday.
So people who want me kicked off of my own
show, which shockingly is a bigger number
than you might imagine.
I effectively am being kicked off of my own
show for all of next week and you'll have
a week break.
Although I never really understood if you
dislike me that much, if you dislike this
program that much, it seems like you could
just watch a different show or listen to a
different podcast or just if you listen on
the radio tune to something else.
But it seems like for a lot of people that's
not a possibility.
They want to be listening to this show.
They just want someone else hosting it, which
doesn't really make sense when it's the David
Pakman show.
I don't know.
But I will be back.
Uh, please be nice to Faron.
Uh, and to Ben, they're going to do a really,
really great job.
They're going to do the regular show.
They're going to do the bonus show for our
members and our patrons.
Uh, and remember that thanks to your support.
We now have the staffing and resources that
we can rotate, break.
So instead of everybody just having to go
on break at the same time, and the show is
just dark for periods, including up to sometimes
two weeks of shows, uh, we still have production
staff when I'm away, and then I come back
and we have rotating production staff and
we can afford to bring in the guest host.
So this is all because of your support over
the last, um, I guess over the last year and
a half to two years, we've really, really
been able to ramp this up.
Uh, so thank you.
Uh, consider participating in that funding
of progressive independent media by grabbing
a membership@joinpacmandotcomorbypledgingevenaslittleasadollarortwoonpatrionatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
Let me know on Twitter at d pacman or at David
Pakman show number one.
How do Ben and Ferran due next week?
And number two, who else would you like to
see guest hosting the David Pakman show?
And they've got to be more or less in line
with my politics, I think to be good fits
for the show.
Um, let me know.
We still got all of today.
We will take phone calls.
I will answer audience questions.
We've got a great bonus show coming up, but
next week the show is not been canceled and
I have not been kicked off of the show.
I'm just going to be off for four days and
then I'll be back.